[Music]
so martin shkreli if you just google
most hated man in america i think he
comes up as number one uh at least he
did at the time when i first heard about
him
he is known for or he's known and hated
for
uh being a kind of a price gouger with a
drug so what he did was he owned a
pharmaceutical company that focused on
like small
like less popular drugs that were like
niche and he would and he bought them so
he bought this bug this drug called
daraprim
and he increased the price
from like 13 to like 500 something
dollars i don't know what it was but the
percent was like he increased it by 5
thousand percent and so
people and then immediately the news
picked this up was like oh man and they
started calling him the pharma bro
because
first he did this they were like how
dare you but instead of apologizing and
walking it back he was like
[__] yeah i did i own this i could
charge what i want you know like and and
like this is america that's the price of
this drug and uh yeah i double down he
doubled down and he loves attention and
he's amazing at getting attention
a lot of the attention is hate but he's
amazing at getting it
and he was only 33 34 when he did this
and this was basically he controlled two
pharmaceutical companies that were each
public at north of a billion in market
cap i think i don't know i don't know i
can't i can't confirm those that might
that might be right but he also had a
hedge fund before that where he invested
in biotech stocks yeah just like he had
done big things and he was he's a very
smart guy uh now people think he's a
crook so some people said he was a crook
because he raised the price of the drug
that's not a crime that's just something
you don't like then he actually got
indicted and went to jail for doing
something that was uh legal which i
think was like he basically
paid investors from one company with
like the stock of his other company and
then like didn't
wasn't clear or something like that i
don't know exactly what he went to jail
for because there's anywhere for two
minutes back he went back to jail or his
like like he didn't get released early
or something like that for threatening
hillary clinton he didn't really
threaten her but he like made like like
a stupid joke on twitter yeah uh
yeah anyway so he he just got out last
week that's kind of the funny part of
this so he gets out
and uh it's like you know
i don't know who's like a famous person
like everybody wanted to be freed it's
like a free young thug or whoever like
martha stewart yeah free martha like
whatever there was a group of people
that were excited about his his arrival
i was excited too because i enjoy
reality tv i enjoy you know the drama
he's like our version of kim he's he's
our
exactly so i wanted to see a plow and so
he comes back and i just started
thinking about
shkreli in general so i have a couple
ways we can go we can go of
things i find very interesting slash
borderline admire about the way he does
things and then there's
what he has been up to in prison and
what's interesting there where do you
want to go i have both
i like both of those so what has he been
up up to in prison and the backstory you
you actually need to mention this the
back story was he was an early user of
your product blab and i spoke to him a
couple times on blab and when the hustle
first launched we were in our first
office so this was in the first six
months we um one of our reporters was
this young woman named brina who was you
know like a pretty uh like a
good-looking woman and he she dm'd him
for a story and he was like hey do you
just want to like fly up here and we
could like hang out and like he was like
asking her out and uh so i had i have a
little interaction with them as well so
we yeah we had a app called blab that
was basically if you've seen clubhouse
it was clubhouse before clubhouse and it
had video on it um so it wasn't just
audio
and uh it got
sort of popular except you know we tried
using it we tried getting podcasters to
use it we we got some kind of like
marketers to use it for their kind of
like promoting their stuff when we
started getting some bigger brands the
nba started using it ufc started using
it oracle
but none of them could hold a candle to
our number one power user martin shkreli
martin shkreli came on the app and
basically broke the app from day one
first time he came on instantly the room
filled up to like 5 000 people
and it was more people that we had ever
had in one room before that hit our max
limit we were like who is this guy
that's when i first googled and found
he's the most hated man in america
and um
he was famous enough to draw a ton of
people in
but he was not famous enough to have
other [__] to do which was the perfect
sweet spot which as i said he is the
most lethal weapon in social media uh he
has since been surpassed by donald trump
and elon musk
as the most lethal weapon in social
media but before that it was martin
shkreli and the reason i say that is
because um
he
creates a ton of content so he would go
on blab every day from about 5 p.m till
2 in the morning
he would be on that whole time
um and he was the master at creating
nightly entertainment like you know
jimmy fallon
jay leno
you guys can't touch this guy in terms
of nightly entertainment because he has
no producers no script no nothing he
would hop on and somehow or another he
would cause enough ruckus that this room
would have thousands of people in it all
night long watching it like we were
hooked to it and we would see this in
our data like people wanted us to kick
him off because again he's a bad guy for
raising the price of this drug and like
he said this thing that wasn't cool but
this guy was driving in hundreds of
thousands of new users to us every
single month and so i was like i'm not
trying to kick this guy off like this
guy's like you know he's where the
action's at um this was uh 2017 2018
castle culture wasn't a thing yet yeah
and i was like dude i'm a startup i'm
gonna do what it takes to get off the
ground like yeah bitcoin used the silk
road to like get off the ground and like
you know youtube started as a dating
site and facebook you know before this
he did face mash comparing like which
girl's hotter like okay not everything
starts with like the most like clean cut
you know i think airbnb started by like
faking and scraping you know craigslist
sites and you know emailing them as fake
people saying i'd love to book your
thing can you just list on airbnb like
dude people do what they have to do to
get your project started started
and so we had shirley and i used to
watch at first what i noticed was
everybody who came in came in to throw
stones
at this evil man who raised the price of
this drug
but he did not sit there and apologize
or whimper he like fought back and he
would give his side of the argument he
would invite you up for a debate and
that's when you saw
how
how strongly held opinions could be with
no logical backing with no real
rationale behind it the argument was so
hollow and this was not just like
average people
people who were like very successful
business people come on trying to like
kind of um
stand on their head you know be on their
high horse uh you know telling him what
he should do and then he would like
dismantle their argument
journalists from cnn and other places
would come on he would dismantle them
um and he's doing a combination of like
a making fun of them
b hitting on them and c breaking down
their logical arguments all at the same
time i've never seen anything like it
and i just thought wow this guy is very
entertaining i don't agree with
everything he's saying but i think he's
very entertaining and the data doesn't
lie he is very entertaining he's and i
think
later on later on in some of the blabs
he would have like these like cute women
in the background and they like clearly
i just met him on blab and he was just
like hey i'll fly you out you want to
hang out this is what started happening
everybody started off hating him so
after about three weeks he developed an
army of believers of people who were
there's a guy who became creeps yeah the
creeps and so this guy he came on his
name was young shkreli and he and when
martin was tired or had to go eat young
shkreli would go hold court and he would
just be like an extreme knockoff version
of martin and he would just hold court
defending him until martin came back to
defend himself and then all these women
started joining and they loved him and
they would just hang out there all the
time and they were like when they were
not like cam girls or model they were
like actual models fashion models cam
girls only fans people whoever and they
would get on and they would just be like
you know martin just like i don't know i
would date you and they would just get
out and they were so the room was always
filled with like his posse it was like
you go to like you know where uh a mob
lord is that and he's got his goons and
he had his goons dude and his army was
just growing by within a couple months
the number of people who loved him
outweighed the number of people who
hated him and it was like the most
surprising thing it was like watching a
cult form in real time it was
fascinating and um i remember the cnn
journalist came on and she was like
martin i you know i know everybody kind
of you know attacks you but i don't want
to attack you i just want to ask you
some questions he's like well you're on
my show let's go she's like no no i want
you to come on cnn he's like this is
better than cnn he's like you're on my
show you have questions let's go this
these are my terms you can ask any
question you want no holds barred right
here right now and if you're not
prepared come back and prepare but you
could do it right here
on my show and she's like i'm not going
to do that martin i can only do it there
he's like and he's like he's like all
right fine come with me to my fundraiser
gala tonight i'll fly you out he bought
he goes he screen shares he buys her a
plane ticket and like he's like what's
your email address i'm sending this to
you and she's like i'm not going on a
date with you martin and he's like who
said it to date uh and he's like you
know he's just playing people perfectly
insane
didn't they didn't she end up quitting
one of the one of the women who hollered
at him from washington post ended up
quitting the job
and so this is part of what's remarkable
when he goes to jail this woman from
washbow or someplace is assigned to
cover him and or cover the story
falls in love with him breaks up like
she has a family she has a husband kids
i think
leaves them for martin falls in love
with martin while he's in prison
and then martin breaks her heart and
she's heartbroken now and like you know
whatever she gave it all up she gave up
her career and her family for martin and
fell in love with him this guy's got
some cult leader [__] to him so anyways
he did some crazy stuff when he was on
blab like he would
he was so loyal to his army that he'd be
like i'm i got a date tonight but don't
worry i'm leaving blab on so he would
leave it on in the other room and you
could eavesdrop and overhear his date
which is again oh my god prime time
entertainment
is it wrong yeah is it entertaining yeah
it is and so this guy was phenomenal
anyway so i found this guy interesting
he would also do things so like from a
marketing perspective i was observing
how is this guy staying relevant like
that drug [__] was years ago like what
how is he staying relevant he would just
do stuff so like wu-tang clan had an
album that they were selling like a
one-of-one for their biggest fans he
bought it for two million dollars so now
this guy that they didn't want so they
even got a feud with him
he had this thing and then on blab he
would play like snippets like 10 seconds
of the album and no one's ever heard it
before besides him but he would just
like tease it dangle it um like the
original nft when um there was like some
building for sale in times square he
tried to buy it for 10 million dollars
to like erect a statue of himself in
times square and again it gets covered
so he was just newsjacking constantly he
was just hijacking the news and putting
did he have money when he got arrested
or like because
i i think he was actually like he they
he showed a brokerage account that had
like 70 million dollars in it yeah i
think he had like somewhere between 50
and 75 million dollars if i remember at
the time but then he like had to declare
bankruptcy
yeah and i think at one point ironically
his attorney that was defending him
raised his price by five thousand
percent and started charging him sixty
thousand dollars per hour and like i
don't know if this is real or not but
martin came out the news like this is
outrageous and like people were like
dude the irony you know pot calling the
kettle black i was like of course this
is just another article he wanted
written about him and like he's just a
master of getting attention he did so
many things like this i can't even count
the number of things he did like this i
was like wow this guy just knows how to
stay in the cycle and i constantly like
reinvent himself because then he would
like just when he pushes you away he'd
lure you back in so like for example on
saturday friday nights he would hold
like you know his nightly blab thing
where he's at thousands of people and
it's like a roast session and he's
saying outlandish [__] and like you just
feel yucky for being in there and then
saturday morning he would wake up at
eight in the morning and he would do a
live finance like session where he would
teach you how to analyze stocks and it
was great phenomenal and i watched a
bunch of them they're still on youtube
you can go watch them he is so he's very
smart and he was so thoughtful and
patient as a teacher he's a he's a
fantastic teacher and so anyway so
that's like the backstory so anyways he
gets out and he said they're like how
was prison right he immediately he gets
out he immediately jumps on
um
on twitter spaces oh by the way actually
that's another funny story when he had
to go speak in front of
congress or
i don't know yeah congress i guess he
had to go testify
um he goes there and he just with a smug
look kept saying like i i will take the
fifth amendment you know i choose to
elect my my fifth amendment well rights
to not speak he just said that on loop
for an hour but he was smiling he was
smugly smiling and just pissing them off
and he was drawing the whole time
and then he gets as soon as he left the
record he jumped on blab from his phone
on the train
and he goes
all right who wants to see my drawings
he shows his drawings of like dicks and
stuff like that that he was drawing on
his piece of paper and he's live the the
hearing was still going on and he
embedded it in one screen and he was
just talking mad [__] about the congress
people in the other screen at the same
time again it was just like high level
social media usage so anyways he got on
twitter spaces and they were like how
was prison he goes
oh it was awesome he's like he's talking
about the prison system and like how
unjust it is and how you know he's like
you know ninety-five percent of the
people that were in there um you know
had like traumatic childhood issues with
parents and stuff like that he's like i
hustled out like other people's lockers
you know where i so i could store more
books
and um
and he's like he basically was like so
what was his like summary stuff so first
he's been blogging have you read his
blog from prison no but what did he say
about prison he was he i mean i bet you
he was actually well respected there
yeah he's like
everyone's like tell me some stories
yeah exactly
um
and so he yeah he was kind of like you
know had his his crew there or whatever
he said he created um a crypto study
group
um so he what did he say he goes
um he goes when everybody else was
working out in prison i would read
because brain gains are all that matters
not muscle gains because he's like
oh my god he's like i created a group
called crypto thugs in prison and it was
just me teaching crypto to um to the
rest of my like my fellow like inmates
or whatever
and he had a bunch of like interesting
stuff so
um
he had a bunch of predictions about
crypto that were in there a bunch of he
read he basically spent his whole time
studying about crypto and artificial
intelligence um and like biohacking and
stuff like that so he's got this blog
post with a [__] ton of predictions
about the future um i'll i'll read you a
couple of his
i'm on his blog it's just it's
martinskewelly.com right uh yeah i think
so
so um let me read you some predictions
on here so 2025 so about three years
from now
uh self-driving cars are the successor
to mobile computing they trend upwards
people spend eight hours a day in your
car
um tesla near's 10 trillion market cap
musk becomes the first trillionaire
2026 an ai generated maybe gpt4 song
gets created with zero human editing and
direct participation and charts on
billboard uh 2013 or 2030. um
virtual reality slash metaverse is
ubiquitous widely used all you needed
was a comfortable ergonomic optical
interface that's what was the limiting
item
i think he's uh wrong on that one 2030
vehicles uh self-driving cars reached
majority penetration in the u.s car
accidents dropped by more than 50
percent and he said he just keeps going
he goes out to like 2050 he's making
predictions as to things like you know
2050. lifespan for a newborn is now 125.
90 of non-surgical medicine is automated
um
blah blah blah like most contract law is
automated on is automated on chain and
so he keeps going now right or wrong you
could disagree with all these but he's
just a very interesting thinker very
interesting guy you follow right and he
does these book reviews that are like
very hilarious where he's like this book
three out of five
uh you know first three fourths giant
waste of time last fourth interesting
about this topic it's like oh good like
you saved me much time reading that book
like i kind of trust your opinion on
these things um and so i don't know his
blog is worth a read
we uh i i tweeted out asked to get him
on the pod but i had no twitter handle
to tag i didn't know who he was or you
know which it was kind of hidden we
maybe found the right one um
but we uh
we should get them on i feel like we're
big enough that we can get them
[Music]
you